Kate hi nice to meet you Connor from
Skye she is the one wanting to film
Nicola sturgeon's shoes
um an eventful 24 hours the women in
charge of the country's finances The
Devout Christian who would have voted
against equal marriage
has your campaign got up in Flames no
absolutely not is it correct for people
across Scotland to have children outside
of marriage um it's it's not it's
something that I would
um seek to avoid for me personally in
terms of my faith my faith would say
that children well it's there's Sexes
for for marriage and that's the approach
that I would practice but so is it in
your view wrong then for people to have
children outside of marriage that's your
view isn't it
I mean you're asking me would I impose
my views on other people I'm just asking
you you think it's wrong well I think
from for me it would be wrong according
to my faith the row over the double
rapist now known as Isla Bryson caused
trouble for Nicholas sturgeon I am
trying to rationally individually what
I'm trying to do the first Minister who
wasn't initially clear on whether the
Predator was a man or a woman a rapist
cannot be a woman and therefore my
straight answer would be the Isle of
Brighton as a man this at a time when
Hollywood had passed laws making it
easier for people to legally change the
recognized gender
I think we do need to look again at
safeguards particularly around young
people I would have been far more
supportive of it being 18 year olds so
you don't support 16 and 17 year olds is
that what you're saying I am seeing that
but that puts Kate Forbes on a collision
course with Nicholas sturgeon's view the
overall position of the SNP the party
she wants to lead and the majority of
msps here in Hollywood it is a huge
gamble but one that she feels will pay
off how's it going good comes the use of
Scotland's current health secretary
feels his path to power is now looking
in good shape whatever the person's
personal views are or religious
convictions are that they don't
interfere with the policy or legislative
process look I'm I'm a practical Muslim
I don't make any bones but I'm proud to
be a Muslim I'm going to be fasting in
Ramadan in a few weeks uh time so far
this contest has been fought on social
issues leaving some in danger in a
campaign which is kicked off with a bang
not quite in the way the SMP had hoped
Connor Gillis Sky News Edinburgh